good morning everybody and welcome to
development control b
my name's kathy guthrie and i'm the
chairman today
now first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
you maintain social distancing from all
other persons whilst in the chamber and
in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or you are exempt from
doing so
and that you use the hand sanitizer and
whites provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations while
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
we will be using e-voting for this
meeting on the modern gov app
so please could members make sure they
are logged in or ready to use the app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consented to being recorded
by the council and to possible use of
those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting
when
the public and press are not lawfully
excluded
if you hear the alarm leave the building
immediately via the fire exit and make
your way to the assembly point ipswich
town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium ground floor
area and walkways
if you are in the atrium at the time of
the alarm follow the signs to the
nearest fire exit
use the stairs and not the lifts
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
so i'll now go to the introductions
please so we have ian duprey our legal
advisor
john pateman g the area planning manager
gemma walker the area planning manager
robert carmichael our governance officer
and we have case officers
marsa
who's here
bradley's not here just yet oh i can't
see you there you are bradley bradley
and daniel
daniel's not here i knew there wasn't
one here yet we also have bethany webb
who's streaming our um meeting today and
we have alicia norman sat up there who's
also an additional governance officer
ward members will make themselves known
as we go through
they are members of the committee
certainly
so can i move to the agenda please
apologies for substitutions
absence
thank you chair we have apologies this
morning from councillor andrew mellon
and councillor john matheson is
substituting
thank you
to receive declarations of pecumvery and
non-pecuniary interest might by members
are there any to declare
no
declarations of lobbying
there are none
declarations of personal site visits
confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 27th of october 2021
now members are asked to note the tabled
paper regarding the draft minute
70.14
and these were sent out as a late paper
yesterday i believe wasn't it yeah
so
are there any points regarding accuracy
of the minutes
in which case can i have a proposal
please counselor muller
and a seconder
please counselor gaston caught my eye
first
thank you
the governance officer will now conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair the electronic vote is
now in progress members could please go
to the plus sign in the in the top right
hand corner of today's agenda the vote
will show in a light blue color about
halfway down the screen
councillor carsten can i take your vote
verbally please
four thank you
didn't come through there could i just
please take it verbally
four thank you
and so chair that that means that there
are six votes for
and
sorry seven votes four and one
abstention thank you chair
so the minutes have been confirmed and
they'll be signed during the meeting
today
so may we have confirmation
of
that's doubled up isn't it oh there's an
additional amount yes jim we have two
sets yeah we did because we had we had
two planning meetings in one week
i forget
so essay 2116 confirmation of the
minutes held on the 29th of october
so again we had tabled papers
um which have been brought to your
attention are there any points of
accuracy on those minutes please
no right can i have a proposal council
muller
and a second
i'll take councillor stringer
so the governance officer will now
conduct the electronic vote please
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress if members again could please
go to the top right hand corner of their
agenda and go to the plus sign on and go
to the sub-section on attendance voting
and there will show in a light blue
color
counselor carsten can i please take your
vote verbally four thank you
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is six votes for and
two abstentions
thank you very much though be signed
during the meeting
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
none received chair
thank you
[Applause]
so the schedule of planning applications
um they will go in the order in which
they appear in your papers
so i now invite uh masa to introduce the
first application dc2003098
land to the south of dis road bottasdale
suffolk thank you
thank you chair good morning everyone
so i think it's best to start with a bit
of background on this application
the current application is for reserve
matters of the approved 69 houses in
buttersdale they access and also arrange
a number of affordable housing units
were approved at outline and secured by
a section 106 agreement
in july 2021 the item came in front of
committee but it was deferred to allow
to allow officers to ensure all plans
match in detail explore improvements to
appearance and for officers to provide
analysis of design policy of the
neighborhood plan
namely design checklist this is all
included in in your bundle for queer
retention
the application side is located on the
southern side of this road on the
eastern periphery of buttersdale the
site's northern and western boundaries
adjoin the village settlement boundary
the site compromise and open open field
the site is joined by residential
development parkview
parkview and
chapel lane on the northern and western
boundaries the sites are joined by
agricultural land to the east and south
as you'll note
this shows the constraints of the site
the site does not form any part of the
specific land designations namely
special landscape area or conservation
area
the site responds well to the existing
constraints
um there's a sewage work to
to the north west of the site and this
to degree determines the reason for
the irregular odd shape of the plot
so the residential dwellings are placed
where the sewage works zone of influence
ends
just excuse me
my point doesn't seem to
work excuse me
um
following the approval of um
outline planning permission the site was
incorporated in in the neighborhood plan
and the policy has been dedicated to the
site
the policy also details the affordable
contribution of the proposal which has
already been signed and agreed at
outliner stage via section 106 agreement
there's a lot of information on this
slide and i'll try to do just this um so
i'll cover some main points
um
i think i need to point out the
applicant has made a great effort
in engaging with the parish and also the
officers to
to come up with a scheme that is
suitable and addresses or initially
raised concerns and also policy
compliant
i'd like to point out to the landscaping
all around the site
the landscaping buffer around the site
and access onto the site in addition to
that the following has been proposed
retention of hedgerow along the site
sudden boundary amenities space afforded
to all house types
addition of two open public spaces all
proposed dwellings under boundary with
parkview are either singular story
dwellings or two-story dwellings with no
first floor habitable windows
facing the parkview boundary
materials reflect some of the
characteristics of the historic village
center for example
red and cream brickwork gray and dark
red pen tile roofs
and render of varying colors
18 visited parking spaces have been
presented
these are all in bays alongside access
roads
an attenuation lagoon located at this
road frontage east of the proposed
access road
what can be observed on this slide is a
mixture of affordable units as i already
pointed out this has been already agreed
so the dots in black represent houses
affordable houses and the ones in red
are flats and there are two blue dots
that represent two bungalows
provision of the three meter wide
pedestrian cycle access to chapel lane
has also been presented to the western
boundary
in addition all new dwellings will have
the means to securely store bicycles in
garages or sheds
proposed affordable housing mix is as
great as i said um
so on this slide
you can see the market dwellings
and also you can see the traffic calming
measures that have been introduced
and additional landscaping to protect
the character of the countryside
where where the development is most
exposed
this slide shows a typical street scene
upon the approach on to the development
from the main access
we also have another street scene
elevational drawing this is from the
west of the side looking onto the west
of the site and you can see i think the
black and white represent the affordable
units i also have some 3d illustrations
of
what's been proposed here
so most of the dwellings are detached
and semi-detached
to story
and i think what the members would be
interested in knowing is
the design of the affordable units
which i'll get to
so this is a typical affordable unit
that's been presented for us
somewhat attached to our legs i also
have some photos from the from the side
so this is a google image and you can
see that
it's on chapel lane
and
the field is where the development would
be you can see some roof scapes of the
bungalows in park views
um
and also this is a hard standing as is
existing but there's a small area of
green space
excuse me just just one moment please
thank you
okay this is better now so um you can
see some
relatively recent development and
the palette of materials and the colors
and
the development that we have here before
us has taken some reference from this
character in the locality
this is parkview
and the development would be placed here
in the field as you can see it's
relatively flat
just more images
from development in church lane
this is mill road
and the roofscape is the bungalows in
parkview and the development would be
placed here
again more views onto the site from mill
road
this is a view onto the site as you can
see just see here from parkview
this is approach onto mill lane and this
is chapel lane
in conclusion
i need to point out that as i said the
applicant has gone through a lot of
effort and have engaged with the parish
and worked with officers to achieve a
suitable scheme that responds well to
all policies
namely neighborhood plan policies and
the local development plan
your offices have not identified any
harm in terms of amenity ecology
biodiversity landscape highways or
heritage matters the parking is policy
compliant design and layout have been
suitably mended to respond to local plan
and neighborhood plan policies and to
address the initially raised consent by
the parish
similarly suitable materials have been
presented to ensure a well-designed
development in buttersdale
therefore the members are respectfully
invited to support this scheme thank you
very much
now before we go to um any questions for
clarity um for the planning officer um
we do have members of the public um who
would as you might have seen the
three-minute
technical device was just put on
robert's desk there who would normally
be able to speak but there aren't any um
representatives from the parish the
objector or the supporter
but so questions will be for the officer
so
it might have a bearing on what you ask
her
so um
any questions for the officer councillor
matheson then councillor gould
thank you
yeah a couple please um firstly i wasn't
actually clear how many bungalows there
are amongst the 69 um properties
and and the other question was
um regarding on the outline condition 18
which is the um
the the results and and
energy efficiency
whether we'd had
whether that condition had been
submitted and what the environmental
management officer response was
thank you
just before you answer that i've just
been given information to say that
actually the agent is here on this one
so it might reflect in your questioning
thank you sorry
so um
this is all included as i said in the
report
there are six flats and two bungalows
and also in response to your
other question
matters if
such as solar panels and also
electric charging points onto houses i
think is that what you're referring to
in terms of sustainability
well there is
there is a condition 18 on the outline
for this um for this site
and i was wondering whether that had
been
um
proposals for that had been submitted
and discharged and what the
environmental management officer
response
to it was
so the condition 18 on the outline says
prior to development being commenced
ultimately we don't have any uh details
for that condition submitted at this
stage
thank you
is that all your questions thank you
councillor i think i'm sorry yeah thank
you councillor gould
thank you i wanted to ask about the
distribution of affordable properties
across
the development
uh
i might have misunderstood the slide
that you showed which appeared to
suggest they weren't gathered on the or
concentrating on the western edge of the
development but if you have a map that
showed the overall distribution of
affordables across the development that
i'd appreciate that
thanks
thank you
thank you so yes as you correctly
pointed out there are mainly two
to the western side of the development
um they are concentrated there but there
are integrated so there are other market
houses within that corner
if you put that the picture up with the
spots on it might help the counsellor
just to refresh you again
sorry we'll get there
yeah i think this is the one
yes so the two blue dots are two
bungalows
the reds ones are the flats and the
black dots are just houses
thank you councillor norris your
question please for clarity
thank you
page 42
9.3 the last sentence
says any conflict with the neighborhood
plan such as the absence of children's
play spaces required by policy b and r-7
is not vital to the application for the
reason so the officer's assessment
included appendix 7 and it was not
secured under the outline position
permission sorry uh but if i look at
the summary on page 59 under appendix 7
it says any other consultant responses
and against it's got not applicable
so i'm a bit confused as to what it's
referring to
and i would also question why there's no
children's play area anyway
and the other question i have is on the
recommendations on page 43
uh no mention of electric vehicle
charging points or cycling cycle parking
which i would thought is something that
we would be promoting
thank you
uh
yeah so there's a few things though i
might have to come back to you on a
couple of those but um
in terms of the play area
the
it's the sequence of events
ultimately the outline planning
permission was granted prior to the
neighborhood plan allocation coming
forward
so the outline didn't secure play space
so that is not
in our remit anymore to deal with
because it wasn't picked up on the
outline permission so the reserve
matters in front of you are for the
appearance scale of the development
before us but we can't add things in
like play equipment at this stage
the neighborhood plan allocation
when they allocated the site did include
the desire to have play equipment
somewhere on the site um but that is not
a because the outline was already there
first we can't go back and and change
the outline
requirements so
that because of the sequence of events
unfortunately on this occasion we are
unable to secure uh the play equipment
um however
ultimately um it might be the case that
any seal contribution made from the
development may go towards player
equipment and can go towards player
equipment
if the parish council do wish to look at
that as an option
for the public open space that will be
provided by this site
going back to electric charge charging
points um no i don't think there's
anything specific
in here i believe it's the applicant's
intention
to ensure that they are all got charging
points
that came forward from the agent
recently did it not matter
um yes we had confirmation that they are
amenable into
incorporating that into design again we
don't have that officially put forward
to us because we haven't discharged the
condition
uh that would probably pick that up
which is the sustainability condition
which is condition 18
on the outline so that is a different
matter for a different time but it is in
our
scope to deal with at a later time
thank you for that john and we can also
ask the agent as well because we don't
need to go too much into debate now but
has that answered your questions
yeah
yeah thank you very much any further
questions for clarity councillor muller
and councillor matheson clarity on these
please yes uh thank you chair um mata
could you please confirm one of the
photographs of the cgi you showed had
chimneys on the house can you please
confirm that
are these chimneys purely for decoration
or are they actually can they actually
be used like a flyer or whatever
unfortunately i won't be able to confirm
that i think that's the question we can
ask the agent for that thank you
yeah the um i see we
we've been asked to discharge condition
12
as part of the um of this actual
application uh which is to do with the
um water
um
anglian water
and i i wasn't clear that they've
um
that they've actually confirmed that
they're happy with with what's been put
forward
i found that this page 67
but that's a year old actually that
that letter
and
so i couldn't i couldn't see that they'd
actually signed off on the on that
condition that we're being asked to sign
off on
john again yes okay sorry um in terms of
condition 12 and 13 both refer to
surface water drainage
which would be picked up by suffolk
county council's flood management team
i'm not aware of any objection from them
on that regard and of course as part of
this proposal at the top of the site you
have that very large attenuation basin
which is part of that approval
okay
thank you very much
um and as i say apologies i was only
given the information late i believe
it's mr adam bell the agent can now come
forward please or you're there thank you
pardon um and you have three minutes on
our
technical device thank you okay good
morning um
chair councillors i'm adam bell
development director at bennett homes
our application was deferred at the
development control committee in july
due to concern that the design policy of
the ottersdale parish neighbourhood plan
had not been fully considered and to
provide time to explore improvements in
the appearance of the scheme
following this we arranged to meet with
representatives of bottasdale parish
council to review the scheme
various queries were raised notably
relating to the dominance of parking
landscaping concerns overlooking of
existing dwellings and the visual impact
of the development when viewed from mill
road to the south
as a result of this meeting our
architect revised the scheme making
changes to the parking arrangements and
reconfiguring the footpath from chapel
lane to provide a more attractive route
into the development
dwellings were repositioned to avoid
overlooking of the bungalows in park
view and a mixed species buffer hedge
has been incorporated along the southern
boundary where the development is open
to mill road
additional planting has also been
introduced throughout the development
the parish requested assurance that the
characteristics of the village center
would be reflected in the choice of
materials to be used and as a result a
material schedule has been produced this
includes plain cream and red bricks and
render and weatherboarding of varying
colors
roofs will be finished with either dark
red or black pen tiles
an additional street scene has also been
produced
at the request of uh rottersdale parish
council
the planning officer for the application
has produced an
analysis of our layout
and has concluded that it does address
the requirements of the neighborhood
plan
i believe that our engagement with
members of pottersdale parish council
has led to the improvements in the
design of the scheme and i thank them
for their involvement i hope that the
application can now be approved and
we'll be happy to answer any questions
you have
thank you very much indeed um
questions for the agent please counselor
mueller thank you thank you um could you
just confirm please if any of the houses
proposed will have chimneys and if so
are these just basically for
uh
well are they going to be actually used
as proper chimneys or just for like a
general sort of um
yeah
i think there are a few
uh chimneys shown in places but they are
decorative rather than active
i think with the building regulation
requirements it's
quite difficult to get an open fire uh
to comply with the energy standards
these days thank you very much
thank you any further questions for the
agent
no oh counselor stringer yes please
thank you
given that most of the environment
enhancements are going to be left to a
condition that that obviously won't be
discussed in in public
and i've looked to see if you've got an
environmental policy uh yourselves as a
company and i couldn't find one how will
these homes be heated
their homes will be heated by air source
heat pumps so electricity no no gas
and we've also
been in dialogue with the with master
and
said that we would put some solar panels
on some of the dwellings and we've also
agreed to put
electric vehicle charging points
on the dwellings
thank you
thank you very much indeed the no more
questions thank you very much in which
case i now open the item up for debate
please who would like to start the
debate
anyone
counselor carsten thank you
um yeah thank you very much so um
yeah the principal's been established on
this i think this design is a good one
um
i
i'm pleased to hear that the
consultation's gone on with the parish
council
and that that's improved the scheme
that's exactly how things should work
um
i'm yeah i'm very happy with this and
i'd be
happy now to propose
that we
we approve this
so with the proposal do i have a second
alert thank you councillor muller
yes thank you chair yes i'll be more
than happy to second this proposal for
approval thank you
thank you and would members like to
speak to the motion please counselor
stringer thank you yep thank you
not much to say thank goodness other
than it's good that
a deferred application at the committee
has then gone on to be improved
uh
and and perhaps that's a perhaps a
lesson for the future as to perhaps we
can
we can have the enhanced design before
it hits the committee in the first place
in future one one tiny little niggle is
always with decorative chimneys because
one earth they're in development i
absolutely don't know because all they
do is create a fault in the roof
within the within the uh
warranty period because the warranty on
the chimney is less than the the roof
tiles and the roof itself so frankly if
we could amend it i'd quite like to get
rid of those if we can because they
serve no other purpose other than to
create nuisance in the future uh other
than that this is this is a
a a a reasonable development
just one other question for the officers
though while i do support this how many
i'm slightly concerned we've got these
conditions about energy and
sustainability that are to be agreed uh
as it were not in public i always think
that's not terribly transparent do we
have a lot of legacy of these i just
want to ask
if i made sure just answer that point um
yes we've probably got about three years
worth um
the problem is when we started to
introduce these it was very much prior
to commencement uh or prior to slab
level uh ultimately we have adjusted
them in the last year to be concurrent
with
reserve matters and i think council
madison was part of that discussion a
year ago
ultimately
given the time frame of planning
applications we've got a couple of years
before we probably start to see those
ones that have had the altered wording
come forward
to have it part of the reserve matters
more up front for members consideration
i can't do any more than that i'm afraid
at this stage
i think we've had that conversation
before and it will keep cropping up but
if members can be mindful of it it's
it's one of those legacy things um yes
councillor matthison thank you yeah yeah
obviously not not having the
those um those matters on condition 18
in front of us is disappointing what i
would say to officers really is um you
know if you can encourage developers to
submit them concurrently um on the basis
that the committees will welcome that um
that would be good to see
but apart from that this is clearly an
improved development um i
i'd like to see the pv panels offered to
every house that's got a suitable aspect
roof
um and um it's a picture there are more
of the houses that actually do have the
right aspect but apart from that i will
support thank you
[Music]
thank you for that any further
comments to the motion um proposer and
secondary do you wish to make any
amendments to your proposal and second
um no thank you um chairman um i i can
understand um
the
issue with um fake chimneys they don't
actually bother me as much as they do
other members and i think they do have
some cosmetic value to the properties
but um yeah thank you very much thank
you and the second
presumably i forbid it for me to put
words into your mouth but thank you for
your confirmation so we have a proposal
and the second can we have the um
the proposal read out for us by the
officer please
so chair the proposal on the table is
just that the application dc
203098 be approved as detailed in the
office recommendation
as detailed currently in the papers
if you're happy with that i will start
the vote so if mems could please go to
the plus sign in the top right hand
corner of their agenda and go on the
subsection of attendance voting and the
vote will now show in progress in a
lighter blue color
counselor casting can i please take your
vote verbally
four thank you very much counselor
thank you chip
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is a unanimous vote
for the proposal
thank you very much indeed i think
that's one of the quickest
applications we've had
so well done to everybody but very good
debate and good paperwork so thank you
that helped us very much so um i think
we can move on without a break at the
moment
thank you yes just walking the table
i'd like to present the next case that
would be good thank you very much thank
that's right yes
so this application is for replacement
dwelling in lax field
this application site is situated in a
remote part of the countryside with no
immediate neighbours
this shows the wider context of the site
as you can see it's surrounded by
agricultural field
this shows the level of isolation of the
site it's the red line
the site is not part of any specific
land designations namely conservation
area especially landscape area or site
of scientific interest
there are no
protected landscape features within or
within close proximity of the site and
there are no
tpos
the site is accessed onto a narrow
narrow country lane
known as cratfield lane
the access is existing and will be
utilized
this is a block plan showing the
position and outline and footprint of
the proposal
the application is accompanied by a
support and agricultural methodist
statement and the illustration
highlights the planting of additional 19
specimen trees we didn't establish
established residential cartilage and
introduced in the southern boundary
hedgerow
the southern boundary is the only
boundary that is exposed to the
countryside
otherwise the site is surrounded by
natural landscaping existing and will be
maintained
this is elevational drawing shows a
two-story traditional design
with maximum height of 8.8 meters
that sits centrally within the plot
the proposal also features a detached
garage
some more elevational drawings
flow plan
this is a detached garage it's a typical
two bay detached garage
and this is a block plan of the existing
existing bungalow which is a singular
story bungalow with footprints of
approximately 200 square meters
part of the structure is to be retained
as part of a proposal and use as a
temporary accommodation if
if permission is granted today
i've called it so we can make a
comparison to what's been proposed
as you can see
in comparison it's the replacement
dwelling would be large
increase of
approximately 50 percent
the existing bungalow
also have undergone some alterations in
extensions in the past
the maximum height of the bungalow is
five meters
this is the roof
outline of the bungalow
and this is the area which will be
retained as part of the proposal
and the rest will be demolished
these are some photos onto the site
shows the view when approaching the site
from the west
onto craft cratfield lane
this is a similar image
this is the approach on to crafty lane
from the east
and this is the existing bungalow
which is in the state of disrepair
oh
your offices have not identified any
issues in terms of ecology by diversity
highways
hybrid safety amenity or landscape
impact
similarly the members are invited to
respectfully support this scheme thank
you very much
thank you very much for that
do we have questions for the planning
officer from members can i just uh
remind some members they may have seen
typo errors that we have corrected
um councillor stringer
thank you chair uh it mentions in the
paperwork that this proposal is going to
have three kilowatts of solar panels on
it which is actually quite a small
scheme but i can't see which roof it's
on
uh on the plans
also
it doesn't mention it but there are
glass balconies here i believe which
aren't in the suffolk design guide but
if you're designing glass balconies they
are bird killers
because birds just hit them uh and i
don't see any details of what is called
clarification where you put etching on
the glass so that birds don't get killed
i'm also
is
there's a
there's obviously generous proportions
of most of the rooms here apart from the
downstairs toilet in the main house
which is not wide enough for anyone with
disabilities to access it i'm just
wondering if if
that's been taken into account thank you
thank you um
in terms of glass balcony
i mean yes we could we could
introduce the condition but
it might be slightly excessive but
that's something that i can check with
my manager to see if
if it is reasonable for us to
include that condition can i just
interrupt you master i think that you
know the members are going to be voting
on this so we need to sort of get a
decision today
and
your manager i believe is there so i
think we need to sort it out so members
have the full
details
john
uh
yeah we've had bird strike come up
before
um
and we can condition you know we can
condition the details of the glass
to
be designed in such a way that
glass you know the birds recognize that
it's there you know etched in some way
et cetera
i've not if i'm honest i've not seen any
we've put a condition on to see details
i've not seen the result of that yet to
see what that comes back to resolve that
problem
we have done it and we can do it that's
that's we can resolve that one by
seeking further details to be agreed of
the glass balconies so notwithstanding
the details we have we can we can seek
that
um i'm not sure about the solar panels
so if you have to give me a minute to
look those up because that was one
aspect if they're on the elevations
uh as for the downstairs uh disabled
toilet um
we would normally refer to building
regulations but i don't know if they
actually would cover that
as a private house um
so i don't know the answers to that
question
i will check for the solar panels and
i'll come back to members shortly
councillor stringer perhaps we can bring
that point up in discussion um and see
what results are managers going to come
up with but good points thank you uh
councillor stringer question for massa
was it not counselor stringer counselor
did you have a question um
yeah i was rather looking ahead a bit
but um i was wondering if we can have a
condition regarding the lighting
scheme um
to be agreed that isn't actually on
there at the moment i didn't see you
here just ask a question rather than
make a statement
is there any provision at the moment
regarding the lighting scheme
um
just to point out all ecology matters
have been can be adequately conditioned
um at the moment we don't have any
details about outdoor lightings
yes council of war boys a question there
uh foul water disposal is proposed
excuse me
um
to be undertaken
on site by a treatment plant i presume
that bungalows already had existing
facility for disposal for it will be a
new system
uh that's proportionate to this size of
this new building
um
just just bear with me one more with a
check
shall we see if there are any other
questions first and then maybe we'll
take a time out while the officers can
have a quick look for the points that
have been raised that are very valid
any further questions for the officer
no then in that case then can we just
take a few moments time out while the
officers look into those um
points please so if you'd like to
stop
there we are we've resumed the meeting
so uh just gave time out first of all
mata you if you'd like to give us your
information and then we'll come to john
please thank you
thank you yes it has been provided that
there will be a sustainable drainage
system and for um discharge of surface
water um
and it's going to be a foul sewage
package treatment plant so that's that's
what's going to be used
yes i assume say yes for that scale yes
regarding the door and the bird strike
issues
right so just clarifying the bird strike
issue uh we are more than happy to add a
condition on to that effect so you see
details on that point just going to the
lighting
matter
we have to have a balance as officers to
say what is reasonable and what is
supported by your policies
at the end of the day this is a
replacement house so we already have a
house here we already have a house and
an established garden this proposal
doesn't seek to extend the garden in any
way
so
the current property can pretty probably
put as many lights up as they want
so
we haven't placed a condition on
lighting
given the material considerations of
what is already there
however if members wish to pursue that
that may be a matter for debate
in terms of the solar panels on the roof
again
uh we don't have any details on the
current plans before members of any
solar panels although i would imagine
obviously this is a new building it
would have to be a income uh would have
to comply with building regulations in
all respects and i would imagine that
would be a far greater standard than the
current building as it stands but no we
don't have any details of solar panels
if members feel it's reasonable given
this is a replacement house to impose a
energy and sustainability condition that
might be an option for consideration in
debate
thank you for that i think it's best
that comes up in debate if that's all
right with you councillor stringer
another question yeah thank you
thank you chair uh the the policy we're
dealing with here is h8 isn't it which
is replacement dwellings in the
countryside because that's where we are
it says favorable consideration will be
given provided the proposal by virtue of
its size and scale does not detract from
the character and appearance of its
surroundings can we i mean
do we have a sort of overall
length width height of the original and
length width height of the proposed
councillor stringer an interesting point
and i'm sure the officer will come to
that but um in this council we don't
have a restriction on size i believe i
don't think we have a policy on that
particularly on on
increasing size and things like that
no but it it it's asking about character
yeah i'm aware of that i was just
throwing that into the
mix thank you
thank you um can i have the slider
please
so the increase in height would be 3.8
meters from the existing five meters
in terms of size i mean the policy
points out regarding the character
this is a residential cartilage and this
will be a replacement dwelling
there will not be any further or wider
landscape impact
from this proposal simply because it's
already bound
by landscaping and also further
landscaping has been proposed
the policy doesn't pinpoint exactly the
percentage of increase
it is a matter of judgment to see what
is suitable the size of the plot is
quite generous so you can accommodate
the size of dwelling that's been
proposed thank you
thank you any further questions for the
officer
thank you very much
i don't seem to have anybody else
available to speak
or any tabled papers from board member
either no
so um may we now go to the
debate who'd like to start that one out
for us please thank you very much
councillor matheson
yes i i
clearly there are no
there are no policy
reasons
that we could possibly
want to refuse this so i think it's just
a question of getting the conditions
right
and
so i'd like to propose a provable
um with the addition of
two conditions
one um to to require wildlife friendly
lighting scheme to be agreed um with
particular reference to our recent
motion regarding the the the color and
intensity
of the lighting
and um a second condition that we we
include an energy and sustainability
um
plan to to be agreed
strategy i think we usually call them to
be agreed thank you
thank you councillor any seconder for
that motion
councillor
norris i'd like to second out i think
the lighting condition is essential
so i won't say any more thank you
would anybody like to speak to the
motion
council of war boys
yes thank you chair um yes i think
the principle of development has been
established but you know when it's an
isolated house like this in the
countryside always
think in terms of what the npps says
where
the design should be of an exceptional
quality
this is a substantial increase in size
which
i do question it's a very traditional
treatment um
but i think you know looking at
an exceptional design can be in
different ways it could be in a way
actually sort of uses technology
uh
the
use of ev cells and also its impact on
the environment so
and support this with a
exceptional design statement in terms of
its environmental
impact
thank you for that anybody else wishing
to say something counselor stringer
just wanted to go back to that issue
about disability access
to a toilet
this is a substantial home
it is
34.4 metres wide
you could fit a terrace of houses in
that
quite easily
what i don't get is why you then cannot
get a wc in here
that's
that's accessible for someone in a
wheelchair it clearly is not good design
if we can't do that surely we condition
that at least one toilet in this
building should be accessible to someone
in a wheelchair
you know
we really we really need to you know
think about the lifetime use of this
building it's got six bedrooms there
could be 12 occupants in this house the
chance is that two of them will be
disabled within their lifetime
we need to think about the lifetime of
the house so i think
it would not hurt the generosity of this
building if awc was was wider than the
staircase
thank you chad um just before we come
back to you councillor um councillor
custon um we'll bear that point in mind
and just see if there's anything else to
add on rather than anything else council
cap just i just wanted to say i wasn't
entirely sure that this wasn't suitable
for a um
disabled person in this house and i'd
just like officers to clarify
because we've got a downstairs bedroom
we've got
a wet room
and a shower room
um it seems very suitable for a disabled
person to me
but
i'd like i'd like to hear more about
just give us some more dimensions please
um
[Applause]
just one moment i'm just going to get
the dimension though
john so at the moment we have a
resolution to approve we've got two
conditions but that didn't include bird
strike so i don't know if you wanted to
add that um ultimately in terms of the
downstairs uh
facilities
on the ground floor plan there is
a wc there's also an ensuite
and i saw a moment ago i thought it's a
wet room the wet room
to my mind has a wc in it that looks
potentially able to have wheelchair
access given the dimensions i can see on
this screen
uh equally
the internal fittings of
showers
where your sofa goes and so on would be
a matter for the applicant ultimately
i have no problem with adding a
condition that at least one downstairs
provision should be suitable for
disabled access if members wish to add
that that would be no problem
thank you for that can i just before i
come back to you councillor um
councillor muller you were going to say
something before we start adding more
conditions thank you yeah thank you chet
can i just have some clarification on
the condition regarding the lighting
john bearing in mind the comment you
made earlier in theory because it's
already an established property that he
could have as much liking as he likes
which obviously we don't really want
because obviously we've got to consider
the motion we did pass before council
last month earlier this month last month
so can the clarification be that it has
to be like sustainable lighting or not
can i just mention their counselor that
um what the comment was was wildlife
friendly yeah
so um
cover that would it not
yeah thank you
in terms of justification you're picking
up on the your duty to consider ecology
and wildlife and i would accept that on
that basis i think
thank you so um councillor matheson
coming back yeah thank you for um
for pointing out the balcony um glass
balcony will be suitably marked to to
minimise bird strike um on the on the
lighting um i had a look at the ecology
submission from the consultee and it
doesn't actually mention lighting so i i
would certainly want to
uh include that in some way or rather
um
into into the conditions
and um i thought perhaps the easiest way
of dealing with the um
the
toilet issue that council string has
raised would be to ask for m42 condition
to be met which would probably be met
anyway by the the other
um other provision on the ground floor
that you pointed out so we probably
wouldn't need to they will probably need
to change anything but that would be one
way of of adding it if that's
is that all right um mr payment g
i think we've got to be mindful of
adding and adding and adding conditions
so long as we make sure that there is
provision for
um so are we happy with what we've got
there
are you happy with what's been discussed
and debated to add on to the
experts
can you add that on or do you need
clarity of what we need right so at the
moment i've got four conditions down uh
one is a condition for lighting or any
lighting external lighting to be agreed
with the consideration of wildlife
friendly
sustainable and energy strategy
condition to be agreed
notwithstanding details of the balcony
the design should be agreed to avoid the
likelihood of bird strike and lastly
in terms of downstairs provision for
disabled wc shall be provided
so um
oh yes cancer casting
sorry that um that condition was for a
disabled wc but um was it yeah i think
access needs to be
added thank you
so as read out by
uh
our officer we have a proposal
and a seconder can we go to the vote
please
thank you chair and just for clarity so
the um proposal that members will be
voting on is the application dc
2103098 be approved as detailed in the
office recommendation with the
additional conditions that have just
been read out by mr paymancy
so members the vote is now in progress
if you could please go to the plus sign
in the top right hand corner of the
agenda and go on the subsection of
attendance voting from there the vote
will show in a light blue color because
the casting can i please take your vote
firmly four thank you
sorry councillor norris is
four thank you very much councillor so
sure that's all votes have been received
and that is unanimous vote for the
proposal
thank you very much indeed we're looking
at my watch in the two cases going on
should we just have a quick 10 minute
break and then come back and reconvene
so if you'd like to
well back are we ready to go again then
please if you'd like to live stream as
we are live stream hello welcome back
and thank you very much indeed
so we now move on to
the next item dc 21
0409 land at iairfield
and i will invite bradley heffer to
introduce the item please thank you
thank you good morning members
ladies and gentlemen
this
item on the agenda
requests members decision
on a full application for a warehouse
and associated office facility on the
site
at our industrial estate
apologies a slight technical hitch
thank you
this slide is an aerial view of the
former warehouse sorry former airfield
site
which has since been utilized as an
industrial estate for a significant
period
the site application site is the area
shown hatched
this is a wider area of view
of the industrial state
and
just to point out on the plan you can
see the line of the a140 trunk road
running along
the left-hand side um and
the other side of the road sorry the
other side you've got the b
1077 road which basically those two
roads enclose the whole area of the
industrial estate and again you can see
on the plan
the the
location of the application site we're
talking about today
this is a site location plan at various
scales i think it's useful because it
does also show
the surrounding form of development in
terms of floor plate
the size of of buildings in the vicinity
which we feel is an important
consideration bearing in mind the use
that's proposed and also the context of
the site in which it would be located
the constraints map as you can see
there's not many constraints in fact
there's only one identified which is the
line of of a footpath which is shown the
dotted green line
to the north
the site for this proposal does not
impact on the line of that footpath
this is the site layout you'll see the
building that's proposed the main
element of which
would be for the storage
warehouse distribution use
the
part you can see here is a projecting
area for
taking on and delivering
goods and services which is covered
this element of the building
is the um associated associated office
use
the access to the site is shown as well
uh the green long spaces you can see the
the um the lorry parking spaces
uh and the blue spaces are car parking
spaces there's additional car parking
shown at the rear which will be accessed
up this side of the building
i think it's also important at this
point to
mention that if you've had a chance to
look at my report
the site is in flood zone one so it's
not subject to fluvial flooding
but it is in a pluvial flooding area so
it's subject to
significant pluvial flooding events
the area that
is covered by the pluvial flooding is
approximately this area of the site here
so um in a highly unusual one in 1000
event
in one year
the extent of water would actually
impact into the building itself
and in the um
1 in 30 event which is the the most
likely event
the the impact would be
less severe it would be around this area
but i think
it's clear
it's important to make clear that this
has been part of the consideration of
this planning application
and as i've said in my report
we've undertaken the sequential and
exceptions test
which is necessary in these sort of
situations
and officers are content that this is
the most
suitable and available or available and
suitable site for this particular use
notwithstanding
the pluvial
impact also improve your flooding issue
that has been identified
so that has been fully considered as
part of this application
this is an elevational drawing of the
office element of the building which you
can see is is
functional um
to take
account of the overall design approach
that's taken with this type of building
on an industrial estate
that's the floor plate of the large
warehouse area the main area
and the covered
delivery and loading area which i
mentioned earlier and there's the office
building
in terms of elevations for the
the main building as you'd expect it's a
fairly simple structure slap pitch roof
single span
cladding metal
steel frame
and i think that the scheme is proposed
to be
utilizing two shades of of grey metal
sheeting
with a contrasting metal sheeting on the
office element
um this is a plan showing the existing
site sections the green dotted line that
you can see
in the plan there
basically these sections run a a b b c c
and d d as they're shown on your plans
so aa for example is the top section
there which gives you an idea of the
the land level at the moment on that
particular point
this is
described as floor plans but really it's
an elevational plan but will give you an
idea of the size of the building in
relation to the immediate surroundings
in terms of scale as you can see it is a
fairly large structure
but it has a square plan which has meant
that obviously
the overall roof span is greater than
um
for example this this building here
which is shown here which has got a more
rectangular plan form so therefore the
roof plan or the roof span is not as
great
this is a useful plan because it
indicates or shows i don't indicate it
shows where
other sites that are operated by the
applicant company are
and again if you've had a chance to read
a report it's one of the the key
elements that i understand to be a
driver behind this is the
rationalization of the industrial uh
of the overall operation of the the
company they do operate some remote
sites
um
and
this is a chance to
rationalize that and and bring some of
that external operation onto the site
near their other operations so
it makes eminent sense in in in business
terms
this um
say this area here this area here this
area here are also sorry operated by the
developer
and the other thing is that these areas
also contain parking facilities
because as you have noticed from my
report
the actual if you operate a maximum
parking standard on this particular site
it's less than the requirement if you do
operate a maximum but in combination
with the other nearby sites it's well
over provided so we're happy with the
the parking allocation
and the highway authority haven't raised
an issue in relation to that
this is um the access of the b-1077
which leads into the industrial estate
and this is the access that will be
utilized as part of the
the proposal
this
is a slide showing
the site in the distance as i said in my
report it is overgrown at the moment
clearly that is the case
and as you approach the site this is
directly opposite which as i say is
functionality is that is the key on an
industrial estate the jobs have to do
sorry the building has to fulfill a
particular job
and that's where the aesthetic has left
us in relation to the new buildings
clearly you can't fail to notice the the
large turbine facility which you see in
the um
in the background
there's a quick
look along the frontage
that's completely overgrown and unkempt
at the moment
and that's the end of my
presentation
the last thing i would like to
mention
is if you've had a chance to look at the
table papers
just to update um
we haven't received any further comments
from local parish councils who were
notified
the lead local authority local flood
authority have removed their holding
objection now recommend conditions
which
we have shown those to the applicant
because they do include pre-commencement
conditions
so we have to agree those
and
that's been confirmed that they're
acceptable
and as well as those we're suggesting
some additional conditions that were
missed off the summarized list
in the agenda that includes the charging
points for cars
cycle parking because that's
a requirement
details of the lighting and
i hadn't picked up in the original
report that suffolk county had asked for
fire hydrants so that's been picked up
as well
plus there's the informatives at the
lead local authority sorry local flood
authority would want to add which have
been included in their consultation
response
so in summary um we feel it's a an
application that's in full accordance
with the policy base
that's adopted for this particular area
the design
and the access and and parking
arrangements and the use
we don't think will give rise to any um
unacceptable disturbances locally
it's an appropriate use and it would
allow
for rationalization of established
business which
again
would be seen as a benefit as well as
the um the job creation which i
understand
would be in the region of 20
to 20 jobs
um there is a peruvian flood risk issue
as we've we've looked at in detail
and we're content as officers that
the um the mitigation of the flooding
and the construction
and
things applicable to that particular
element have been adequately addressed
hence we can give you a positive
recommendation
at this committee thank you
thank you bradley before i go for
questions um we did mention in briefing
regarding sewage um what sewage
treatment plant was going to be used
apologies chair yep the in terms of the
um sewage treatment it's going to be a
package treatment plant
um
that's shown as uh indicated on the
application drawings which i understand
is a treatment and then releasing to
groundwater areas of of of the treated
water thank you
thank you and also um you've just
mentioned the additional conditions so
they are already
if you like not set in stone but they
are already available for members to con
to add on to what we've already got
that's correct yeah good okay so does
anyone have any further questions
councillor gould oh oh
yeah exactly the point
i'm just going to make a point of
clarification
but uh as discussed with you but if you
want to do that maybe more appropriately
please do it yourself okay
thanks uh
just for the clarification of the
committee i am as you know the award
counsellor here
but discussed and agreed with the chair
because i'm i'm
not going to make any uh
any representation on on this item uh
being in support of it as is the town
council which hasn't made any uh
objection to it uh i would swap the
chairs leave to stay where i am
here rather than move elsewhere i hope
that's still
acceptable madam chair yes indeed if you
just stay where you are because
obviously cleaning desks and everything
so you'll take no part in this i did see
a hand up it was councillor stringer and
then councillor warboys please thank you
very much thank you chair uh
is
you mentioned the policy base page 187
188
is core strategy 2008 cs3 still a
current policy
um i haven't listed it in the the you'd
have to remind me i can't remember the
top of my head which way that's why i
was asking
policy cs3 in the core strategy clearly
says that all non-residential
development over a thousand square
meters will be required to integrate
renewable energy technology in order to
provide at least 10 percent of the
predicted energy requirements and
additional sustainable construction
measures
so my question is if that policy cs3 is
still current
why has that not appeared in that list
and why do we not see a condition
for it to be implemented
apologies it's not in the list but there
is a condition with regard to approval
of sustainable
elements of development and construction
um that's included in samurai's list
at the end of the report
i i take that point but that policy is
also not quoted by our sustainable uh
environment officers response either so
it it's either part of the policy base
that we're using or it isn't uh and i
suggest it should be in that policy base
if it's still a current policy
german do you want to comment on that
please because
correct cancer is a current policy one
that we still use it should have been
referenced that's
error on our part i don't know if that's
something that necessarily needed
reference by the sustainability officer
but perhaps we can make particular
reference in that condition of the that
wording of the policy as part of our
proposal and obviously make sure that
that's included in the um decision
notice if members are minded to follow
the approval
any further questions councillor warboys
thank you
thank you chair
um
yes uh
it's um
it's to do the flooding situation the
water disposal
um
which you've referred to already um
but the the next and i wasn't really
worried about it until i read the next
application
where there's a detailed report from the
waveney lawyer on loving land
drainage board which talks about
sustainable drainage systems
and
[Music]
you know
attenuation of the discharge from the
site in particular as a sort of sewage
treatment plant is going to go into the
drainage system after
treatment
um i just wondered how that tied in with
what you've already told us about the
flooding risk
um thank you councillor the
um issue in relation to my one was
um we hadn't we had an uh holding
objection from the lead local flood
authority
which we've been looking at in terms of
the sequential and exceptions test
that's been taken back to the llfa
and on the basis of their findings and
discussions with them they are now happy
to
recommend
an approval
subject to imposition of various
conditions
and the conditions include
strategy for the disposal of surface
water for example
um and implementation and maintenance
and management and strategy of disposal
of surface water so i think just trying
to summarize briefly what they're asking
is that notwithstanding if you were
minded to accept the approval
uh the recommendation there's another
step
in relation to dealing with the details
of the sustainable drainage surface
water drainage
system that would need to go through
that further check with them i'd picked
up that we hadn't consulted the drainage
board on our one
but i think as an officer i'm content
that the advice i've given you in
relation to surface water drainage
is you know sufficient in order for me
to feel comfortable giving you that
recommendation i see so there'll be
compliance with the drainage board's
recommendations at the future thank you
thank you for that bradley any further
questions
no oh counselor matheson yes
thank you yeah
is the land immediately to the north uh
in the same ownership or or is that
um not not open to us in any way
am i right it's already developed is
that the one where there's a gap in the
uh um there is a useful plan i can i can
um hopefully i'll get the presentation
up again
i'll show you um
oh
sorry
um no this is a short one so the land to
the north is not in the ownership
if you mean immediately to northern
boundary
yeah it's not edged blue um the edge
blue
sites are the bits that the company
currently owns or occupies yeah
well it's assumption they own or occupy
if it's a blue
so um
so i think you've got the answer to the
question if you want to use it as a
debate we can do when we get to the
debate but that's we're looking at the
red line for today
thank you for that any further questions
no
in which case thank you very much and we
have
um
oliver jones who's the agent you have
three minutes if you would please and i
note we have stephen potter and sean
bartram to answer any questions should
they
uh
be required to do so you have three
minutes please thank you
thank you um yeah i'm oliver from
pandasil i'm the agent the application
and directors of bathrooms with me as
well um we haven't really got anything
to add on what um bradley's already
presented to you happy to answer any
further questions you may have
and if you have anything in regards to
flooding etc i'm happy to answer them
thank you any questions
at all
now being polite i will go back to the
ward member just to say from what he's
heard is that anything you wish to say
as a ward member for which you are
entitled to do so
are
no objections from uh locally
relationships interesting that parish
councils
of registered uh no objections
um this is an important local employer
the development is seen as appropriate
in the settings the situation has been
greatly assisted by the construction of
the two roundabouts on uh the a140
i was pleased to see the in the table
papers the additional uh positions in
terms of vehicle charging points and so
on and so forth so uh for
so
a key local employer key part of local
economy uh and i'd be very pleased to
see this application supported
any questions for the counselor
counselor stringer for the counsellor
to the agent is that possible yes yes i
didn't see your hand up earlier it must
have been a slogan it didn't so
my error
please ask the the policy cs3 does
state that we should
make sure that at least 10 percent of
the predicted energy requirements are
integrated into the building
plus additional sustainable construction
measures
i can't see any details of that in the
application but would that be possible
with this design
yes certainly we've already gone back
and said we're happy to incorporate
solar panels and ev charging points and
in terms of sustainable construction
we'll be looking at it we've obviously
designed the drainage to be sustainable
already in terms of using attenuation
and discharging back at greenfield
runoff rate the foul water is dealt with
the treatment plant so again it's
treated and discharged at the correct
run-off rate and that system is already
designed
as in regards to the construction of the
building we'll certainly go through the
details of that and pull together
anything we can do as well
happy for that to be conditioned if it
needs to be
thank you very much
in which case no further questions for
the ward member
then we now go to the open debate who'd
like to start that councillor muller
good chair
yes thank you very much bradley for your
presentation
i'm really pleased to hear about the
additional conditions you've added into
that that's really really important and
from what i've read and what i've heard
today i've been more than happy to move
approval to grant the application thank
you chair
thank you i have a
council of all boys
thank you very much councillor warboys
to second thank you very much
councillor stringer
can i be assured that that is including
a condition to satisfy cs3 because if
you read the papers page 221
our response from our environmental
management officer is that the applicant
may wish to consider
no it's actually
policy that they should implement not
consider thank you and bradley would
just like to help us on that one thing
um i'd picked up from the early comment
council i think that in drafting that
particular condition we will make
specific reference to the cse cs03 so
it's absolutely clear the requirements
of policy got to be complied with
so um i have a proposal in a second that
anyone else wish to speak councillor
casten you had your hand up but it might
have been for something else
i might hand up to second but yeah i'd
i'll be voting in favor of this i think
this is a really good extension to a
good mid-suffolk local business a good
employer it's it's good for the area and
i'll be happy to support it
thank you very much anybody else wishing
to speak
in that case um so long as we are clear
on what has been read out for the
additional conditions and are you happy
with what you have available yes go to
the vote for this goodness yeah i've got
um an updated
recommendation that i put into mon.gov
so that members can see as well but i'll
read it out for clarity is that
zero nine dc2104099
the approved as detailed in the officer
recommendation on page 197 with the
additional conditions as detailed in the
table papers on page seven
so
thank you chair so i will now open the
vote for members which will now show in
progress so if members could please go
to the plus sign in the top right hand
corner of their agenda
and go on subsection on voting and
attendance there the vote will show in a
light blue color
counselor casting can i please take your
vote verbally four please thank you
chair there's just just a point i just
need to clarify because councillor gould
has voted as an abstention
no not at all i'm afraid
that's that's quite a right answer what
i would suggest and sharing the redo it
was to read yes it's to redo the vote so
um just so that all meant parties are
clear and that we are um
apologies
right so uh if you bear with me two
moments joe we'll just re-run the vote
so
the vote is now in progress again
can i can i please say four thank you
thank you chap oh
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is a unanimous vote
before the proposal noting the counselor
called has not voted on as the wall
member thank you thank you very much
indeed so we now move on to
the application
dc 2104 697 which is also land on eye
airfield ipswich road i and it's
case officer daniel cameron if you'd
like to introduce this matter please
thank you very much indeed
and just before we start on this one
just to make it clear that councillor
gould is the ward member and he's
staying in his seat because we don't
need to
clean all the tables for him but he will
be speaking as world member
and so daniel over to you please
thank you chair
yes similar sight
not too far removed from where we were
just looking at
um
let's see our site
here members and then the site we were
just looking at was
located here
um again this is a full application for
the erection of a b8 warehouse
in terms of uh updates um we have no
further comments from broome and oakley
parish council yaxley parish council of
the anderson parish council
apologies chair um
and
for clarity
um
within the um
comments from consultees the flood and
water team have come back with suggested
wording for conditions although they
haven't at the time of this meeting
given as a lift of their holding
objection but i'm understanding that is
to be imminent
we come slightly further up we can see
the access point is the
normal access point for the wider site
and again we have the a140
running down diagonally
as members
if we come to the slightly wider view
again we can get a better idea of the
the airfield site as a whole and the
wider surrounding landscape
and then we come here we have the
application here members will possibly
remember
previously
dealing with the two
warehouse buildings adjacent those are
now erected as you'll see from the site
photos
the only constraint we have again is
probably right away which comes and
curls around the southern boundary of
the site
um
an informative has been requested by the
public rights of waiting with regards to
the
responsibilities of the landowner with
regards to public rights of way this can
be added to the
list of informatives members have at the
end of the report
and then again we have a fairly
utilitarian building but given its use
and its location adjacent to buildings
of a similar design
it's considered that the design is
reflective of what we already see within
the area
and materials are
proposed to
match visually the colours and finishes
of the
buildings adjacent the site
the agents also provided detail in
response to the comments of the flood
and water
fire and rescue team
there's a hydrant main hydrant located
at the access to the site
and then from that we also have
water points within the site as well
this is a view of the site from the a140
which i think most members of the public
will be familiar with the design of the
buildings is just to
reflect
those of the existing on-site
and if we move on site
we can see the run of development
of similar buildings here and we also
have the turbine
and then we have the site itself we have
another turbine to the rear and the
site's already been cleared and leveled
ready for development
and then this is the view
here members so the footpath would come
down
the site and around the back end of the
hedge the hedge isn't proposed to be
affected during development
um
so if members feel comfortable they can
make the decision on whether they feel
the
informative needs to be added
by way of additional points just in
listening to
the debate on the previous item again
cs3 is missing from the list of policies
given in the report that's my error
however in terms of the condition we do
have the condition brought forward by
the sustainability officer and i'll
liaise with the previous presenting
officer to ensure that the condition
reflects ces3 in its requirement so that
that can get taken forward and that
we're not applying different conditions
effectively on the same site to two
different buildings
um
additionally with regards to
the comments of the internal drainage
board
the discharge of the surface water from
this site is going to be taken into a
suitable attenuation basin which again
is proposed to be extended to better
cope with additional flows arising from
this development
uh the only other thing i would like to
make clear for members in case it isn't
clear from the submitted report the
requirements of the highway authority
with regards to parking
um also include
parking of hgv vehicles on the site and
we also have a condition for the
provision of electric vehicle charging
points within the site as well
there's nothing further to add and we're
at the end of the presentation members
so i'll turn back to yourselves if you
have any questions based on the report
thank you for that members any questions
for the officer counselor boys thank you
right of way the footpath it's been
[Music]
it's got a bit of history to it uh could
you just explain to me what the
informative would be
so the informative details the
legal rights for public rights of way
and it just makes the applicants aware
of the separate legal processes they'll
need to go through should they want to
divert or stop up a public right of way
during construction and just makes them
aware that they'll need to go through a
separate process with suffolk county
council
sorry
um does that include actually sort of
making it clear where the footpath is
um so the run of the footpath will
already be agreed within the definitive
map
the suffolk county council will hold and
there'll also be a description that goes
along with that so any any diversion of
the footpath would require a change to
both the description and the definitive
map
and that's given by a legal process that
suffered county council will oversee
i can't see from the
the plans brought before us
that actually there is a need to
divert the public right of way stemming
from this development there might be a
requirement to stop it up during
development if there is a particular
safety concern
but again that would be subject to
separate legal process that southern
county council would administer
thank you
thank you
uh page 246
paragraph 9.2
mentions recommended conditions from the
environmental health officer
including controls over hours of
operation
in the list of recommendations on page
247
it mentions controls
during building
and limit to construction hours of work
further down but i don't see anything
about hours of operation
and the other
question i have is on page 257
suffolk fire and rescue service
in red text
emphasize a condition is required for
fire hydrants i don't see that either
thank you
so with regards to the
hours condition that's likely my mistake
in drafting a report so yes one of those
should be
a
condition to control the hours of
of operation for the building with
regards to the hydrants
it was felt that
the building was sufficiently close
within fire and rescue requirements
such we didn't need to
impose a condition to require an
additional hydrant on the site the
site's already close to the attenuation
basin which would provide water and the
hydrant location and the access to the
site as well as two other water points
within the site as well so it wasn't
wholly
deemed necessary by officers to impose
members may want to take a different
view and we could impose that as part of
the the resolution should members wish
to approve the application
thank you any further questions
no um well i don't seem to have anybody
else
except our board member
i can refer the committee to my previous
answer
as they say in terms of again
important to local economy
transport issues greatly ease through
the addition of the roundabouts which
i'm not sure were
shown
on the plans we've seen but
i hope the committee will be able to
support it thank you
thank you very much any questions at all
in which case i can open the debate if i
may please
we'd like to start us off
counselor muller
thank you chair um bearing in mind what
the the ward members have said that the
town council and i are happy with this
proposal and he is also happy with it
i'll be happy to move approval
on this particular application chair
thank you
thank you very much i'm councillor
carsten
have it's a second manager
thank you very much
and who would like to speak to motion
councillor stringer yeah thank you chair
uh we'll be supporting this just to make
a note on this one the senior
environmental officer did mention cs3
in this one but it then didn't feature
in the list of policies again i don't
want to moan about it but we have
declared an emergency
and this policy was made in 2008 it
should be running through it like a
stick of rock thank you
thank you councillor
so councillor norris and then councillor
boys
i will be supporting this uh but i would
just like to clarify that the
recommendations will be changed to
reflect the limit to the operating hours
of work and i would prefer that the
recommendation from fire and
suffolk fire and rescue service was
actually shown for far hope
thank you
the officer is nodding his head in
approval of that uh council of war boys
did you want to speak
yes i'm happy to support this with the
understanding that the informative
regarding the footpath is incorporated
into it
thank you and
the cs3
is the proposer and second are happy for
an informative to go
accordingly yes thank you chair we're
happy with that and also with the fire
hydrant and the conditions of hours
working etc thank you
yes me too um i agree and i agree with
cancer stringer that um cs3
needs to be um
brought to the fore thank you madam
chairman
the admission right so if we can go to a
vote then
please robert can you share i just need
to clarify um if i could just clarify
with my colleague gemma walker regarding
conditions just so that we've make sure
we've captured all of them yeah just
what i was going to ask thanks rob um so
i've got the approval as recommendation
that's recommendation on page 247 with
an additional
fire hydrant condition
um
and an informative note regarding the
public rights of way what i haven't
added on is any condition on the
construction because we've got both
control of hours of work for building
and limit to construction hours of work
so they are both already bullet points
in there was that the concern members or
was there something else
for that
query
lovely
is that okay rob so i've got the
recommendation as page
247 with an additional condition for
fire hydrants and an informative note
about public rights way
so that's already in the condition and i
think we've said we'll take that away
and obviously
revisit that without it from the list it
was admitted from the list we'll make
sure that's included absolutely
thank you chair so i've i've changed the
recommendation to be that that
application 2104 697 be approved as
detailed in the office of recommendation
with the additional conditions and
informative notes as read out by the
area planning manager just all members
are clear on that so if that's okay i
will start the vote
thank you if members could once again go
to the top right hand corner of today's
agenda and go to the subsection on
attendance and voting there the agenda
the vote will show in a light blue color
counselor caster could i tell you please
take your vote verbally
four please thank you counselor
thank you chair all votes have now been
received um just to note as well again
as this application is in council called
toward he's unable to vote uh but
there's a unanimous vote for the
proposal
lovely thank you very much indeed well
we're playing musical chairs again now
without moving
the next application is in my ward and
the vice chairman dave muller will be
taking the chair for this application i
will be able to speak
but obviously not vote um so
councillor muller over to you to take
the chair
um
thank you very much um i would now like
to
invite the case officer daniel cameron
please to introduce the application of
the committee and this is dc 20
02129
land south east of low road debenham
thank you daniel
thank you chad um
yes this application has been before
members before and some of you may
remember it it was previously determined
by the planning committee on the 9th of
december 2020
and it's come back before you as there's
a
issue arisen in regards to the drafting
of the section 106 agreement
pursuant to that decision and it regards
the type and form of affordable housing
to be delivered on site
the report outlines
the issues for you members
just to quickly refresh
this is the application site we've got
debenham to the north west and east
here we have the slightly wider view
we have the red line plan
previously on the
9th of december 2020 detailed the issues
around
flood zones at the site access
and members may recall that
the site is brought forward by the
neighborhood plan along with the
neighboring site to the immediate south
and we also discussed um during that
meeting a potential section 106
mechanism whereby should this site come
forward we could close up the access
to low roads and if the neighboring site
was agreeable take access through to it
for the avoidance of doubt members the
affordable housing plots are these three
here
and then these three
here at the top of the site
the site itself proposes 18 dwellings
and six to be brought forward as
affordable housing and along with
adoptive policy
um and the housing mix is for six three
bed houses three three bed bungalows
three two bed houses
three two bed bungalows and three one
bed bungalows and of these all three of
the two bed houses and all three of the
one bed bungalows are offered for use as
affordable housing
um the issue arises over the ten year
split of the affordable housing within
the scheme
the applicants have come forward to say
that would we consider an offer of
three units the three one bed bungalows
for affordable rent
one two bed unit for shared ownership
and two units for discount market
ownership
um
with regards to this the council
strategic housing team have said that
they prefer
their standard approach of 75 affordable
rented 25 shared ownership come forward
on the site however in looking at the
application
the
shma basis for that split dates back to
2003
and in looking ahead to
the shimada supports the joint local
plan we do have an acknowledgment that
we need to bring forward a great degree
of discount market units within our
affordable housing packages um and the
policy that would be coming forward
under the joint local plan
recognises that
um the mppf and his most recent revision
at paragraph 65 also requires at least
10 of dwellings brought forward on a
major development site which is sites of
10 or more dwellings and be made
available for affordable home ownership
in effect discount market homes
with regards to the discount market
homes offered the applicants have come
forward with the scheme to say that
we'll be looking at a local links tie to
those units such that those with
connections to debenham and then the
surrounding villages are marketed to
first before being marketed more widely
within the district
it's also proposed the discount on the
market value for the two properties be
30
and that the maximum purchase price for
the properties be limited to 250 000
pounds
the strategic housing team's mix
preferred mix ignores the requirements
of paragraph 65 but is reflective of our
standard requirements however is not
reflective
of
where the underlying evidence from the
shma shows us we need to be going and it
is not reflective of the emergent policy
within the joint local plan
and it it's considered by officers that
an element of discount market ownership
properties within the affordable housing
mix would be advantageous at this point
given that the mppf supports that
delivery and our own policies will see
their delivery come forward before too
much longer
the recommendation before members is
therefore that they accept the tenure
mix offered by the applicants and
instruct officers to continue
negotiating the section 106 agreement on
the basis of that mix
however i'll turn over to members for
any questions stemming from the report
and allow them to move into their debate
thank you very much daniel um do you any
question do you remember us have any
questions council madison please
just one did we not get an any
current um response from the strategic
housing saying that um yes they agreed
with officers or um
or not
their preferences of the 7525 split
continue to be applied to this site
do we have any more questions from
members please
no
it's a leslie short who's the agent mr
short you have three minutes
um
when you're ready please thank you chair
good morning
good morning members the development is
approved for 18 dwellings total and so
defined as major development to which
paragraph 65 of the framework applies
in such circumstances i.e that of major
development at least 10 percent of the
dwelling should be available for
affordable homeownership
10 of the 18 number approved is 1.8
dwellings and so rounding up to the
nearest whole number that's two
dwellings
so if one dwelling were placed in shared
ownership and the other in discount
market then at least two dwellings
tenure of the six affordables due to be
delivered is sorted
we've designed three bungalows which you
rarely get as a housing authority for
affordable rent
so the six affordables proposed the
tenure of five of them should not be in
question
with three number affordable rent one
number shared ownership and one number
discount market that leaves only one
remaining affordable dwelling to be
allocated to tenure and you might be
interested to know for your own
management of such applications
this has taken six to nine months to get
here on this simple point
to assist i turned to the council zone
2019 later update to schma and the table
which appears in your report
of course the requirement to reflect
evidence of affordable housing need is
contained in paragraph 62 and 63 of the
framework together with annex 2
definition of affordable housing
where a need for affordable housing and
i quote has identified planning policies
should specify the type of affordable
housing required and expected to be met
on site that's paragraph 63.
given that the council's 1998 local plan
policy h4 was based upon a housing needs
survey undertaken in 2003
updated in 2005 and the policies was
altered and altered and adopted in 2006.
it's a little longer the tooth now is a
policy applicable to housing tenure
needs in 2021
it's also out of data relations
requirements of the 2021 framework and
its definitions of affordable housing
nevertheless it's still worth pointing
out the policy h4 states and i quote
negotiations with developers will take
account of the identified local needs
your council's 2019 shmar identifies
housing needs by tenure in the district
surely members will see that it's the
latest available evidence on affordable
housing tenure requirements to meet the
identified need going forward
if not what's its function what's its
purpose in relation to your emerging
joint local plan which it underpins and
is currently before an inspector under
the premise that it is the council's
latest evidence of afford affordable
housing need by tenure
we must strongly advocate that the
council accepts the 10-year split as
offered by my clients and let's get on
with the job of delivering them thank
you
thank you mr shaw do members have any
questions for mr short please
thank you very much indeed mr short
thank you
i'll now ask the uh the ward member um
country guthrie for her comments please
thank you very much indeed um well first
of all um
the parish council hadn't responded
because i think there was a bit of a
mix-up of the parish council have
changed their um
email address so um
i did make them aware of it um
no as soon as i got this last wednesday
but they don't seem to have come up with
any
response against this which
doesn't surprise me at all i'm sure
there'd be an approval of it
i like the fact that debenham is going
to be offered everything first i like
the split myself
just as a personal point
the
shared ownership is a very useful tool
for some people but we did have an issue
in debenham
some years ago now where the people
couldn't sell their share because there
was a restriction on it
to sell it to somebody in debenham so i
hope there isn't a restriction on the
shared ownership as to who it can go
back to
but i'm very supportive of this and like
you mr short i'd like it to move forward
swiftly
so i hope that the committee will be
voting for it thank you
thank you guthrie um do members have any
questions for council guthrie please
no
then we'll move into debate council
stringer please yep thank you chair uh
yeah i share
some of the reservations of the ward
member about shared ownership i know a
number of families where shared
ownership has become an economic
cul-de-sac for them uh and with sort of
ever sort of pressing needs of housing
and it's becoming quite a a an active uh
agile market with people's lifestyles
changing quite quickly shared ownership
can be approved to people moving on so
frankly this is a this is a tiny tweak
as far as i can see to what uh this
committee already had agreed to uh you
know almost a year ago
so
without any haste i would certainly move
approval on this uh and and actually
yeah i thought i would hope this could
have been resolved without this getting
back to committee thank you chair
thank you council stringer we have uh
members voted for approval for this do
we have a second to please counselor
warboys thank you we haven't just
thank you
do you have do any members wish to speak
to the motion
no
okay um
could you please
yep i'm happy that's what recommendation
is page 291
thank you jim
thank you chair so um the vote is now
showing in progress if members could
please go to their modern.gov app and go
to the plus sign in the top right hand
corner the vote will show in a light
blue color you may have to scroll down
cancel the casting can i please take
your vote verbally
four please
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and noting as in the council's
planning charter the council guthrie
cannot vote as she is the board member
that is a unanimous vote for the
proposal
thank you very much indeed for that um
do we have any site inspections that
need to be reported to committee none to
report yeah
thank you for that but before we go um i
think i would like to
offer my grateful thanks to my wingman
who has not only done things at this
committee but helps me in many issues
outside and i really will be sorry to
see you go
um but i have to say what a wonderful
thing you've done you took this up you
took it running and you've now developed
into such an excellent officer so i
personally will miss you and i'm sure
everybody else will
but what i would like to also do is to
welcome alicia norman who's got big
shoes to fill but i know she'll fill
them
and so we welcome her as our governance
officer so thank you very much to
everybody and now close the committee
you